こんにぢは。はじめしゃちょーです
（145451454545145454545）
ブッブッブドゥエドゥエドゥエドゥエドゥエドゥエアッドゥエドゥエドゥエドゥエ
ブルブルブルブルブルブルアアアアアアアアアアアア!!!!
おおおおおおおおい!!!!
俺　は　今　日　ぉ
怒ってるぞぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉ!!!!
くそぉ！
（はじめパンチィ！）
ウラァ！
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
ちょっとねぇあのねぇホントに久しぶりにねぇ俺ぁ今怒ってるよ
ざけんなぁ！おい！
ウォーイ！ウォー！オーーボボボ！
ッーーーーー！！
フッフッフッフッフッフッ
ウァアアアアアアアア!!!!（キットカット「解せぬ」）
うめぇぇぇぇぇぇぇ!!!!
あのちょっと話を戻すと
今東京にいます
ほら
昨日からちょっとお仕事で東京に来てまして
で、もう今日も仕事で東京にいるんですけども
東京の家に帰ろうと思って帰ったら
あのー東京の家の鍵を忘れました！
俺よミスだよおぉぉぉぉ
なんで忘れるんだよぉおおおおおおお!!!!
オレのミスだぁぁ!!!!
それに関しては俺のミスだ
全面的に謝る
ごめんなさい
オァッ！だれにだよぉぉぉぉぉ!!!!（今世紀最大の荒ぶり）
それであの帰る場所がなくてぇ
僕は漫画喫茶
漫喫に泊まりました
そこで事件は起きました
その前日もあまり寝てなくてすごい眠くて
で今ちょっとある撮影が終ったんですけど
なんか今日の撮影大変そうだなと思ってちょっとちゃんと寝ようとおもって漫喫行って
あの広いねこうなんか
そしたらぁ！
隣の関の野郎がぁ
とんでもねぇ野郎だったよ
どうとんでもないかは見ればわかると思います
どうぞぉ！！
ｸｺｫｫｫｫ　　（フォン）
ｽｰｰｯ
（フォン）
デン！（あまりのショックにト〇ック状態）
うるせぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇ!!!!!!!!
うわ、うるさっ
おぅおぅおぅお前ちょっと…
えっ（失望）
いやいいよ。百歩譲るよ、百歩譲りますよ
ヒャ↑ッポ譲るよ？
百歩譲って僕が言いたいのは
あのまぁぼくはうるせぇって思ったんですよ
もういびきっていうのはもうそのなんか寝てるその人も寝てるから無意識にでちゃうものなので
僕はもう怒rrrrrrろうと思っても怒rrrrrrれないわけなんですよ！
くそぉ！チェっ！
だってそうジャン
俺の隣の人はねたぶんね悪気があったわけじゃないんですよ
悪気があっていびきをかこうと思ってたわけじゃなくて
もう寝ちゃってるから無意識にあの騒音が鳴り響いたわけです
それ漫喫の中全体に
ｸﾞｺﾞｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｯ
ﾌﾟｼｭｰｯ
ｸﾞｺﾞｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｶﾞｶﾞｫｯ
ﾝｺﾞｫ↑ｫｫｫｫｫｫｫ↓
手が出そうになるよ！
そりゃもう手が出そうになるよ
ｸﾞｺﾞｫｫｫｫｫｫｫ↑ｯ
さらにここうるさいのが六本木の漫喫なので（ﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝｗｗｗ）
なんか上でねクラブがあるのか分からないんですけど（ﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞﾄﾞｗｗｗ）
ずっとドンツクドンツクドンツクドンツクいってるんですよ（dddddddddddddd）
ウゥンァァア///！
ｸﾞｶﾞｧｧｧ↑ｧｧｯ！！
（ここ解体新書のアレ）
そしてさらには
ｷｭｰｰｰｰｰｰｺﾞ
ぬわぁんの音だよ！！
ふつうキューって何の音だよ！
もううるさすぎて
怒りで
漫画の内容が頭に入ってこなかったよぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉ!!!!
そして早送りにしてみると
なんか
ｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯｻﾞｯ
ゲームの洞窟の音楽みたいになったよぉぉぉぉぉぉ！！
はいということが実は漫喫でありました
いやもちろん・・・もちろんですよ
鍵を忘れた僕のミスでもあるんですけども
いろんな人が使う場所で
大きな音を立てちゃだめだと思うんですよぉ
でもあなたいびきをかいてたから
わざとやってるわけじゃないわざと迷惑行為やってるわけじゃないから
叱rrrrrrろうにも叱れなかったんですよ！
かといってそれをわざわざ漫喫の店員さんのほうに行って
「すいませんあのいびきうるさいんですけど」って言うのもなんか
「うわ、なんかすげぇ気にするタイプの客だな」みたいな感じに思われるのも嫌で
どうすれば良かったんですかぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ!!!!
ま、どうしようもできなかったんですけども（ボソッ）
もう結局あのその結果もう
うるさくてうるさくてイライラしてイライラして
もうどうしようもなくて
ﾃ↓ﾃ↑ﾃ↓ﾃ↑ﾃ↓ﾃ↑ﾃ↓ﾃ↑
（いびきじゃなくて寝言がでかいせいで）
（漫喫では絶対に泊まらいことを）
（誓う自分がここにいるが僕だけじゃない事を願う）
ﾃ↓ﾃ↑ﾃ↓ﾃ↑ﾃ↓ﾃ↑ﾃ↓ﾃ↑
ｺﾞ・ﾏ・ﾀﾞ・ﾚ
ｺｯｺｫｯ
ﾝｺﾞｫ↑ｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｶﾞｶﾞｶﾞｯ↓
ﾊｧ…ﾊｧ･･･
ｺﾞｫｫｫｫｫ
はじめ：ウッグフン…